if you've created a linear model in r
you may have seen these four graphs that
appear when you plot your model in this
video we're going to cover exactly what
these graphs mean and how you can use
them to interpret the validity of your
model i also have a video covering what
the summary output of the regression
means and you can watch that by clicking
the card in the corner anyway let's get
started
our data set is going to be the same
from last time it contains the species
weight height and width of different
fish and i'll put a link to it down in
the description we're going to start by
loading in our two libraries radar and
dplyr radar for loading in our data and
dplyr for manipulating data and working
with data frames and we're also going to
load in our fish.csv into this data
frame called fishdf
we can run our code and take a look at
our fish df data frame we see that we
have the species weight height and width
of about 159 different fish
now let's go back to our code and build
out a linear model
we want our linear model to be able to
predict the height of a given fish based
on the width and the species
we'll name our model fish model
we'll call the lm function height is
going to be our y variable
and we're going to predict it with the
width and the species of the fish and
the data we're going to be using is our
fish df data frame
now we can go ahead and create our
linear model
and if we want to take a look we just
have to look at the summary
and we get our output now if any of this
is confusing to you i have a video
explaining exactly what this output
means in the context of our regression
so i recommend watching that first but
before we start plotting our model let's
just refresh on what assumptions we need
to meet in order for us to be able to
use a linear model the first assumption
is linearity the relationship between
our x and y variables should be somewhat
linear
the second is homoscedasticity this
means that the variance of the residuals
should be the same for any value of x
third is independence the observations
should be independent of each other and
fourth is normality this is the
assumption that the residuals are
normally distributed we'll come back to
all of these in a bit but for now we're
going to plot our model and look at the
plots
so we can write plot fish model
and run that code let's take a look at
the first plot though the residuals
versus fitted values a residual is the
difference between the observed value
and predicted value so if we put that in
the context of our data set it's a
difference between the actual height of
the fish and our model's prediction of
what the fish's height should be so if
we were able to perfectly predict the
height of every fish then the residual
would be zero for every observation
however most models aren't perfect at
predicting so there's usually going to
be a residual that'll either be positive
or negative
so the residual versus fitted graph can
be helpful in telling us if we're using
the appropriate type of model for our
data set
we're using a linear model so we want to
make sure that there's a linear
relationship between our variables what
we're looking for are the residuals to
be both negative and positive and to be
randomly scattered throughout the graph
with equal variability like this the two
things we want to look out for in the
graph are heteroscedasticity
and a non-linear relationship
heteroscedasticity the opposite of
homoscedasticity essentially means that
the variability of our predictions in
this case the predictions of our heights
are not equally variable throughout
translating that to our graph we would
have heteroscedasticity
if the residuals were closer to the zero
line for some values but then further
away for different values
in fact that's exactly what we see here
the residuals are initially close to
zero but get further away as our
predicted height increases now
conceptually this would make sense
because if we have a tiny fish with a
small width it'll likely have a small
height but as the width gets bigger and
bigger it might be hard to predict if
this is a long thin fish or a short wide
fish now just because we have
heteroskedasticity it doesn't mean that
within species are bad predictors for
height
it does mean though that we won't be
able to accurately predict heights
consistently and should look into adding
maybe more variables into our model now
the other thing we want to look for in
the plot is a non-linear relationship in
that case we'd expect to see weird
patterns in our plot for instance we
might find the clump of residuals all
below zero for some fitted values and
then another clump all above zero for
other fitted values in this plot even
though we have some heteroskedasticity
there's about an equal number of
residuals above and below the zero line
throughout so there's likely a linear
relationship here between the height and
then the width in the species but what
would this plot look like if we were
instead predicting weight based on width
instead of height based on width now my
assumption is that weight would increase
a lot quicker than width because the
relationship isn't linear so let's
actually create a new model and take a
look
we'll create a new model called fish
weight and here we're predicting the
weight of the fish based on the width of
the fish
and again the data we'll be using is our
fish df data frame and we can also call
the plot command with our fish weight
linear model and run the code
now if we look at the residuals versus
fitted graph we definitely see some
weirdness in our plot first of all all
the residuals have low variability for
the small weights but pretty high
variability for the larger weights so we
already know that there's some
heteroskedasticity here another thing we
see are a lot of positive residuals for
the lower weights negative residuals
around the middle and then huge positive
outliers towards the large weights
conceptually this would mean that we're
predicting very low actually negative
weights for the smaller fish and then
predicting weights that are too large
for the medium-sized fish and then we're
just really bad at predicting weights
for the big fish because there's a lot
more variability so we can definitely
assume that the relationship between
weight and width here is non-linear or
else the residuals would be more equally
above and below the zero line so now
we're going to move on to our normal qq
plot or the quantile quantile plot and
we're going back to our initial linear
model which was predicting height based
on width and species of our fish
so as i mentioned before one of the
assumptions of linear models is that the
residuals should be normally distributed
this normal qq plot can actually show us
if those residuals are normally
distributed by comparing them with an
actual normal distribution
if we think of the classic bell curve
normal distribution where the mean is
zero we'd expect the distribution to
look something like this
about 70 percent of the data would be
within one standard deviation of zero
and about 95 percent of the data would
be within two standard deviation away
from zero
in fact if we look at the x-axis which
is labeled as theoretical quantities we
see that there's a lot of data points
clustered in the center with most data
being between negative 2 and 2 and just
a few extremes on the end this is
because the data points are actually
normally distributed in relation to the
x-axis
now let's take a look at the y-axis or
the standardized residuals
we're still talking about the same
residuals as last time the observed
heights minus the predicted heights and
just like the x-axis we've standardized
all those residuals by centering the
mean on zero and each unit represents
one standard deviation so if these
residuals were perfectly normally
distributed we'd expect the points to be
straight and follow that dashed line
since we know that the points are
already normally distributed along the
x-axis instead what we see are outliers
on both sides of our data set
we'd expect 95 of the data to lie within
two standard deviation away from the
mean but we see a lot of data points
below the negative 2 line and above the
2 line so this means that our data set
likely has a lot of extreme values and
that there are a relatively large number
of extremely short and extremely long
fish so it's a little difficult to
predict what the heights are going to be
just based off of this model so our plot
actually also labeled some of these data
points that are outliers like number 5
and number 30 up here
so what i want to do is actually create
a new table and compare these predicted
heights with the actual heights and see
why the numbers are so off so i'll
create a new table called fish
predictions that's going to use that
fish df data frame and we're going to
add a new column called predictions
we're going to call the predict command
and pass in our fish model and then
we're going to tell it that the new data
is going to be fish df which is
essentially our original data source so
all it's doing is creating a new column
with the predictions and appending that
to the original phdf data frame we can
go ahead and run this and take a look at
fish predictions so if we take a look at
our data frame and we look at
observation number five here we're
predicting that the height is going to
be 14.7
in reality it's 12.4 and it seems like
the reason we're predicting such a high
height is that the width and the weight
are relatively high compared to what
some of these other fish are similarly
if we go to observation 30 we're
predicting that the height is about 17.1
based on our weight and our width but in
reality the height is 18.95
so we're massively under predicting here
and that's the reason that the residuals
are so extreme in this situation
so now we're going to take a look at our
third plot the scale location plot which
is also called the spread location plot
and this shows us if the residuals are
spread equally among our predictions so
we can check the assumption of
homoscedasticity or equal variance of
the residuals we've got the fitted
values on the x-axis similar to our
first plot but the square root of the
absolute value of the standardized
residuals on the y-axis if we want equal
variance in our residuals we'd want the
dots to be pretty evenly scattered
throughout the whole graph and show no
pattern and we want our red line to be
relatively horizontal we already
determined from our first plot that the
model violates the assumption of
homoscedasticity since the variants of
the predictions are larger for longer
fish and we can pretty clearly see that
the y values tend to increase the larger
that the fitted values become and the
red line reflects that with this slight
upward trend so as you probably have
figured by now there's definitely some
overlapping information between the
plots so you may not be checking all
four plots when doing an analysis of
your model but it certainly helps to
know what each plot is trying to show
and the last plot we're going to look at
is the residuals versus leverage plot
this plot helps us find influential data
points if any because our linear
regression works by minimizing the total
error over all observations
if we include data points that lie way
outside the rest of our data they could
actually have a pretty big impact on our
model
another way to put it is that the data
point may not follow the general trend
and if we include it our model might
drastically change just to minimize that
one data points residual so looking at
this plot we have leverage on the x-axis
and standardized residuals on the y-axis
leverage essentially means how much
influence does the data point have on
the model instead of trying to find a
pattern we're actually now just looking
for values in the upper right or lower
right corners these would represent
points that have a lot of leverage so
very influential on our model but also
have large residuals so they're pretty
far off from our estimate specifically
we want to see if there are any points
that lie outside the dashed red line
cook's distance meaning they have a high
cook's distance score so if we had data
points that were like this and we
removed them from our model they would
likely have a big impact on the
coefficients and the intercept of the
model but in this case we don't really
have any influential outliers that we
need to remove
but what i'm going to do is manually
modify our fish df data frame and show
you what it looks like when we have an
outlier that we probably should remove
from our model
so i'm going to set our first
observation's height to 100
so i've set the height of the first
observation to 100 i'm also going to
recreate our fish linear model and then
plot the model and i can run all this
code
and now we see this data point
observation one that lies outside our
cook's distance line so we might want to
remove it from our model if we were to
see this in our data
so now we have a pretty good
understanding of the four plots that are
part of the linear regression along with
the summary output
i'm going to add some additional
resources in the description if you're
interested in learning more but thanks
for watching the video and i'll catch
you in the next one